equal rights for all
the internet has opened new
communication channels for people with
disabilities
a german online activist shows how you
can use blogs for political agendas
porbst is at the church congress in
hamburg the hearing impaired blogger is
angry
she wants to follow a debate with german
president joachim gaok
but she can't see him from her seat
ironically the discussion is about
rights for people with disabilities
the 31 year old doesn't let up until a
new row of seats are set up for people
with hearing disabilities
it's a small victory but for julia
probst this is just one step
the blogger has an assignment the online
magazine of the dia cooney charity wants
her to examine the accessibility for the
disabled at major events
she sends her observations to around
twenty four thousand twitter followers
sometimes every five minutes
in her blog nine augenshmas or feast for
the eyes
she examines issues that are especially
important to her
the internet has drastically changed the
lives of the hearing impaired
her dedication and unpaid involvement
won her nomination for the bobs
the competition for online activism
since 2004 deutsche welle has been
honoring international bloggers with the
award
this year's prize went to chinese human
rights activist lee chen peng
julia popes was the runner-up
german journalist falk steiner convinced
many on the jury that she deserved
recognition
in germany things are improving for the
disabled but there's still a long way to
go
in many countries the disabled are shut
out they're severely disadvantaged and
at the bottom of what we call society
that's why it was important for me to
bring it to the attention of the
international jury
blogging alone is no longer enough for
julia porbst
for 10 months she's been a pirate party
candidate for upcoming elections to the
german parliament
where she hopes to fight for equal
rights for the disabled
she's seen for herself how intolerant
the world around her can be
after one tv interview she received a
lot of hate mail
much of it from people who made fun of
her voice she took a break
reconsidered her candidacy but decided
to push on
yeah the corners
you're going to perfect the ice pack
about your beautiful
dragon the election to parliament is set
for september the 22nd
it will decide if germany is ready for a
hearing impaired parliamentarian
schiff says a woman with a mission